في صباح صحي نبداه بملف غذائي وسؤال جوهري
يقول ما العامل الحاسم لتغذيتك ان تاكل
متى تشاء او تاكل ما تشاء بمعنى اخر توقيت
تناولك للطعام ام نوعيه هذا الطعام ما هو
سبيل لحرق الدهون وانقاص الوزن السؤال
المزمن طبعا دراسات غذائيه تشير الى ان
تناول الوجبات الكبيره في الصباح والصغيره
في الليل يساعد في انقاص الوزن لانه عمليه
الهضم تتغير على مدار اليوم بعدين بس برجع
وبقولوا لك كمان يا عادل بانه لا لا هو
على حسب عدد السعرات الحراريه لا شو شو
بتاكل ولا بعدين قالوا لا مو هذه الطريقه
طيب في المقابل دراسات اخرى تشير الى ان
كميه الطعام في الفطور والعشاء تؤثر على
الشهيه وليس على الوزن بالتالي تناول وجبه
افطار كبيره لا يسجل فوارق كبيره في
الدهون والانسولين وسكر الدم
[موسيقى]
بحسب الخبراء هناك 16 نوعا من الاطعمه
تدعم فقدان الوزن وتعزز صحه العامه نذكر
ابرزها سريعا اول هالبروتين الخالي من
الدهون اذ يعطي احساسا بالشبع ويقلل
الرغبه في تناول الطعام كذلك هو الحال مع
البروتينات النباتيه كالبقوليات التي لها
نفس الفوائد البيض فهو يحتوي على جميع
الفيتامينات الاساسيه الى جانب الكونه
مصدر البروتيني كامل الخضروات بجميع
انواعها خاصه الداكنه منها وايضا
الافوكادو الغني بالدهون الصحيه التفاح
الغني بمضادات الاكسده وكذلك هو الحال مع
التوت المكسرات والبذور فهي مصدر جيد
للالياف والدهون الصحيه والبروتين وبذور
الشيا التي تمنع الافراط في تناول الطعام
سمك السلمان الغني بالاوميجا 3 والروبيان
الذي يقلل من الشهيه حبوب الترمس والشوفان
الخام مهمان لازاله الدهون العنيده
المخزنه حول الخصر على كل حال سالنا الناس
في السعوديه ما الاصح برايك ان تاكل متى
تشاء او ما تشاء نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بصراحه اكل متى ما احس اني احتجت للاكل
وبحكم اني انسانه رياضيه فبعد الرياضه هو
اكثر وقت ان الانسان يحتاج ياكل الاكل
يكون فل بروتين والله يعتمد صراحه قبل كنت
تاكل متى ما بغيت ومتى ما تشاء على قولتك
بس الحين دامنا في عيال صرنا مرات نرتبط
بالدوام يلزمك
رده العيال من المدارس مرات فحتى لو كنت
جوعان ما راح تقدر تاكل وخصوصا ان عيالك
بيجون بعد شوي بتاكل وياهم
اللي وقعت معينه بالاكل استغرب من بعض
الناس مثل ما جاءك لا غلط في وقت الفطور
وفي وقت للغداء في وقت العشاء والحمد لله
طبعا في مقوله تقول افطر فطور ملوك وتغدى
وتعشى فقراء
معنى لا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو خبيره
التغذيه وفاء حلمي اهلا بك يا وفاء اهلين
يا صباح الورد صباح الخير يقال انه اتغدى
واتمدى هيك بنقول
نتعشى وتمشى مع المقوله 100 وفاء عملها
بتطلع بتناقض الدراسات اللي قبلها انه هل
الموضوع يتعلق بعدد السعرات الحراريه بغض
النظر شو بناكل وايمتى بناكل عدد سعرات
حراريه معينه باليوم ولا عنجد في هناك
فروقات ما بين اذا اكلت الصبح اذا اكلت
الظهر او اذا اكلت بالليل شوفي هلا
خلينا نتفق على شيء واحد اولا كل شخص له
خاص خصوصيه تامه في عمليه الحرق وفي شغله
بنسميها البيزن اللي هو الاساسي وهذا
يختلف من شخص لاخر ومن الذكر للانثى ومن
البالغ والطفل فبناء عليه على الاساس هذا
احنا منحدد انت شو بتحرقيه كاساس
اذا انت عندك زياده في عدد الدهون فاحنا
بنوقفك على المشيج وبنشوف جسمك من جوا
يعني هاي طريقه يعني هذا الموضوع يمكن
قياسه لازم يجب قياسه بدون ما فيك تشتغلي
اولا من وقفك او منعمل تحاليل طبيه كامله
عشان نشوف النقص اذا في اي شيء ناقص في
الجسم لانه كل شيء يؤثر تخيلي على الوزن
نقص فيتامين دال الحديد الزنك هاي كلها
الها دور خلصنا منها الجزئيه جينا على
البيئه اللي هو بتوقفي على المشين ببين
لنا
العضلن بالضبط في جسم الانسان في شغله
كتير مهمه انه كتير ناس ما بتعرف انه المي
الداخلي في الخليه نفسها بتاثر على نوعيه
العضل يعني بمعنى انه انا ممكن شخصين زي
سيد عادل نفس الطول نفس الوزن لكن الكتله
العضليه عند السيد عادل ممتازه لانه ما
عنده ممتازه ولكن الاخ اللي عنده نفس
الوزن ونفس الطول الكتله العضليه عنده
سيئه نتيجه اللي هي طبيعه الاكل نرجع
لسؤالك الاول هل فعلا يجب حساب السعرات
الحراريه نعم هل التوقيت مهم وانا زي ما
في احدى اللي حكت غدى افطر مثل الملك
وتقدم صحيح مئه بالمئه لانه الفطور له
اهميه جدا كبيره
وحضرتك تفضلت في البدايه وتكلمت على انه
لا شو ما اكلت بيفرق الفطور اهم وجبه
وللعلم
النوع النوع والكم والساعه البيولوجيه
والتوقيت كله مهم
يعني ابائنا او الجيل السابق كان يكون
الوجبه دسمه وجبه الفطور لان عنده يوم
طويل وبالتالي يتغدى احنا ما عندنا هذه
الطاقه اللي قاعد نحرقها مثل ما كانوا هم
يحرقوها لكن عندنا هذه العادات الغذائيه
مستمره ايضا اللي يروحون على الصيام
المتقطع يقول لك لا
اخر وجبه تاكلها الساعه سته او الساعه
سبعه وتنام الساعه 12:00 بالليل او فتره
كبيره ما بين النوم وما بين العشاء هل هذا
صحيح ولا لا ليش حاقول لك ليش بدايه في
ساعه زي ما تفضلتي في البدايه كمان تكلمتي
على كل شخص له ساعته فلا يستطيع التطبيق
اعتماد الشيء الانترنت او الصيام المتقطع
جيد لفترات معينه ولكميات معينه ومدروسه
مش علاقه
يجب ان تكون في ساعات طويله ما بين العشاء
وما بين النوم
ما في
داعي من هذا الوقت علشان نحرق ما اكلنا
طيب
خلينا نشوف شو قالوا الناس سالنا انه احنا
سالنا الناس في الشارع الاردني شو هو
الاصح برايكم انه تاكلوا متى تشاءون او ما
تشاؤون خلينا نشوف يلا
[موسيقى]
احيانا فرصه انك تاكل اكل انت ما عمرك
جربته او مش من بلدك او اشي غالي مثلا
تفضل اكل شو ما بدي
لانه بكون عندك دائما خيارات كثيره والاكل
خيارات واسع جدا فبتخيل بحب اختار ايش بحب
اكل وقت ما بدي لانه
لانه بحس انه جسمي طالب انه اكل
بهذا الوقت
[موسيقى]
بفضل اكل شو ما بدي
يعني انا شو ما بدي انا اللي باكله لانه
مش شوي بالاكل فباختار الاكلات اللي انا
بحبها اللي انا بتناسبني وعلى مزاجي تفضل
اكل وقت ما بدي بس يكون برضه كمان زي ما
بدي يعني بنفس الوقت الوقت مهم ولكن كتير
مهم يعني
الجانبين كتير مهمات وقت ما بدي شو ما بدي
لانه اغلب وقت جوعان فاي المعده
[موسيقى]
عمليه ترتيب لحياتنا ممكن تغير فكرك تماما
كتير احنا من الناس يمتنعوا عن وجبات
معينه هي بالاخر احنا الاكل اللي بناكله
هو مخزوننا
لمستقبلنا ان شاء الله عند الكبر فتخيلي
لما انت تمنعي نفسك من اشياء معينه ضروري
كل شيء له دور في جسمنا عندي دقيقه
الحرمان يولد ايضا جوع مئه بالمئه
اليوم مع كل ما نشاء وقت ما نشاء ولا لا
ناكل ما نشاء بتحديد الوقت يعني حاعطيكم
بس بثانيه
رتبوا اكلكم بتوقيت منتظم بمعنى فطورك
خليه يكون مثلا سبعه سبعه ونص هلا يعني
عندك من سبعه مثلا وبعدين الغدا يكون برضه
بنفس الوقت واثنين والعش اء نفس الوقت بس
قبل الثمانيه
بالليل ودائما
نقول مثلا اذا اربع ساعات ثلاث ساعات
لاربع ساعات قبل النوم لو تاخرت ما تنام
قبل ما انك تكون على الاقل مشيت لحتى تقدر
تهضم ومش قبل ساعتين من اي وجبه اكلتها
متاخر اذا اضطريت تاكل المنتخب شغله ثانيه
بس بدي اقول لكم انه صعب او تنظيم الاكل
الدراسات اثبتت اذا ما رتبنا الاكل واكلنا
بعشوائيه خليني اقول
18% بتفرق معك في زياده الوزن
لا احد للحديث بقيه الحديث بقيه بدنا نزبط
المشاكل شكرا جزيلا لك خبيره التغذيه وفاء
حلمي كانت معنا في الاستوديو
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات